You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步路。我们省了多少钱？够了。足够让我们迷路了！或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. A few decades ago, the idea of being able to interact directly with a computer using only your thoughts would have sounded like science fiction. But today that technology is here. Commercial companies are
希尔顿促销活动现已开启。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 8 折优惠，获得你期待的住宿体验。当你想要的是优惠，而不是惊喜时。住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为你而住。几十年前，仅凭思想就能直接与计算机交互的想法听起来还像是科幻小说。但今天，这项技术已经成为现实。商业公司正在
testing brain computer interfaces that allow paralyzed patients to move a computer cursor using their thoughts. Other researchers are exploring prosthetic limbs that patients can control directly with their brains. Even as these technologies move forward, practical challenges and ethical challenges and ethical questions remain. How do brain computer interfaces work? What uses are researchers exploring for them and what are the biggest challenges they face? What have scientists learned about the brain as they develop these technologies? And in the future, will brain computer interfaces be limited to medical uses or will we all someday be able to access the internet directly with our thoughts? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
测试脑机接口，让瘫痪患者能够通过意念移动电脑光标。其他研究人员正在探索患者可以直接用大脑控制的假肢。即使这些技术在不断进步，实际挑战和伦理问题依然存在。脑机接口是如何工作的？研究人员正在探索它们的哪些用途？它们面临的最大挑战是什么？科学家在开发这些技术时对大脑有了哪些了解？未来，脑机接口会仅限于医疗用途，还是我们所有人终有一天都能通过意念直接访问互联网？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Nicholas Hatzopoulos, a behavioral neuroscientist and professor of organismal biology and anatomy at the University of Chicago. Dr. Hatzopoulos holds a PhD in cognitive science and a master's degree in experimental psychology. He studies how our body's movement is encoded in the brain, and he's been working on brain computer interfaces and neural prosthetics for more than two decades. Thank you for joining me today. Thank you very much. Appreciate it.
我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是尼古拉斯·哈佐普洛斯博士，他是芝加哥大学的行为神经科学家、生物学和解剖学教授。哈佐普洛斯博士拥有认知科学博士学位和实验心理学硕士学位。他研究身体运动是如何在大脑中编码的，并且在脑机接口和神经假体领域工作了二十多年。感谢您今天加入我的节目。非常感谢。不客气。
Let's start with a definition, as we sometimes do on this podcast. What do you mean when you talk about a brain computer interface or a brain machine interface? What kind of technologies do those things encompass? So it's basically any kind of device that interacts with the brain directly. So it could be either feeding information into the brain or receiving information out of the brain. So it can span a whole variety of different technologies. I've been working on one particular version of it for providing patients with the ability to control devices to move things. But there are a whole collection of different devices that fall under that definition.
我们还是像往常一样，从定义开始吧。当您谈论脑机接口或脑机界面时，您指的是什么？这些技术涵盖了哪些内容？基本上，它是任何直接与大脑交互的设备。它可以是向大脑输入信息，也可以是从大脑接收信息。因此，它可以涵盖各种不同的技术。我一直致力于其中的一个特定版本，即为患者提供控制设备来移动物体的能力。但该定义下涵盖了各种各样的设备。
Well, how do these technologies work? When a person is controlling a computer cursor with their thoughts, what kind of brain signals are being recorded and how does the computer translate those thoughts into action? Okay, so what we do is we implant electrodes in a specific part of the brain that's involved in controlling movement, and we are picking up electrical signals typically from individual neurons or small groups of neurons that are firing as a person thinks about moving their limbs. And we extract those electrical signals with these electrodes, we amplify the signals with electronics, and then we send these amplified signals to a computer that then decodes
那么，这些技术是如何工作的呢？当一个人用思想控制电脑光标时，记录的是什么样的脑信号？计算机又是如何将这些思想转化为行动的呢？好的，我们所做的是在大脑中参与控制运动的特定部位植入电极，我们通常会从单个神经元或一小群神经元中获取电信号，这些神经元会在人思考移动肢体时放电。我们用这些电极提取这些电信号，用电子设备放大信号，然后将这些放大的信号发送到计算机，计算机随后进行解码
these signals into information that's useful for the person. So we take this pattern. Ultimately, these signals are like little pulses because their neurons fire action potentials, which are these very brief voltages that last about a millisecond. So it's like, it's almost like a digital computer in some ways because it's the neuron is either firing, it's sending the pulse or it's not. And so we have these pulses, these patterns of pulsed activity, we send those pulse patterns of activity through a decoding algorithm that then controls something, whether it's a cursor, a robotic arm, an autonomous robot, or a variety of other things. So what does it feel like for the person using the device? I assume that you talk to people as you're working with them. And how hard is it
将这些信号转化为对人有用的信息。所以我们采用这种模式。最终，这些信号就像小脉冲，因为神经元会发出动作电位，这些是非常短暂的电压，持续约一毫秒。所以这在某些方面几乎就像一台数字计算机，因为神经元要么在放电，发送脉冲，要么没有。所以我们有这些脉冲，这些脉冲活动模式，我们将这些脉冲活动模式通过解码算法，然后控制某些东西，无论是光标、机械臂、自动机器人还是其他各种东西。那么对于使用该设备的人来说，感觉如何？我假设您在与他们合作时会与他们交谈。学习使用这样的假肢有多难
for a person to use to learn such a prosthesis? Well, there really are two kinds of brain machine interface philosophies, actually, if you put it that way. One is what's called biomimetic, what basically means we're trying to mimic the way the real biology works. we're taking the signals that would normally move your arm or your hand and instead move a robotic arm in hand. And that kind of biomimetic approach takes no learning at all. In fact, the subjects learn immediately.
对于一个人来说？嗯，实际上有两种脑机接口哲学，如果你这样说的话。一种被称为仿生学，基本上意味着我们试图模仿真实生物学的工作方式。我们获取通常会移动你的手臂或手的信号，转而移动机械臂和手。那种仿生方法根本不需要学习。事实上，受试者会立即学会。
And before we work with humans, we work with animals. These animals were able to control devices without any learning. just immediately do it. There's another philosophy, which is non-biomimetic, which is basically taking these signals as if they don't mean anything. They're just arbitrary signals that then are sent through an arbitrary decoding algorithm, which then sends commands to the prosthetic limb, let's say. And the patient or the animal or whatever has to learn through just practice.
在我们与人类合作之前，我们先与动物合作。这些动物无需任何学习就能控制设备。只是立即做到。还有另一种哲学，即非仿生学，基本上是将这些信号视为毫无意义。它们只是任意信号，然后通过任意解码算法发送，该算法随后向假肢发送指令。患者或动物必须通过练习来学习。
in many ways it's sort of like what an infant has to do you know infant they have to they they're thinking about moving their limbs and they they've never done this before and they have to they flail their hands around and they say oh if i think this way my arm goes this way i'm you know let's say they're looking for a little toy or something out there they try to try different attempts and they flail a little bit with practice they eventually learn it and infants learn to sort of reach and grasp objects over the first year of life. So it's sort of similar in that way, which basically these people learn to figure out how to control this prosthetic limb by creating the right patterns of electrical activity in the
在很多方面，这有点像婴儿必须做的事情，你知道，婴儿必须思考移动他们的肢体，他们以前从未这样做过，他们挥舞着双手，他们说，哦，如果我这样想，我的手臂就会这样动，假设他们正在寻找一个小玩具之类的东西，他们尝试不同的尝试，他们挥舞一点，通过练习，他们最终学会了。婴儿在生命的第一年学会了抓取物体。所以这在某种程度上是相似的，基本上这些人通过在大脑中创建正确的电活动模式来学习如何控制这个假肢
brain to move the limb the way they want to. And I've used both approaches. Is there research going on in areas other than motor control and other devices that interact with different parts of the brain besides the motor cortex? Yes, there is. In the case of movement, there's another group working on the parietal cortex, which is just behind the motor cortex. And that area also carries movement information, but it seems to be sort of earlier, it reflects
来以他们想要的方式移动肢体。我两种方法都用过。除了运动控制之外，还有其他领域的研究吗？还有其他与运动皮层之外的大脑不同部位交互的设备吗？是的，有。在运动方面，有另一个小组在研究顶叶皮层，它就在运动皮层后面。该区域也携带运动信息，但它似乎更早一些，它反映了
sort of the initial intention to move. So when you first intend to make a movement, that area seems to light up earlier than the motor cortex, which then lights up later when you actually execute the movement. So people are looking at devices in that area. It's not clear which area is better, but both areas work. What are the biggest challenges in the field right now in terms of developing neural prosthetics that could be widely available to patients? I think there are two challenges in my mind. The first is as an engineering challenge, which is developing electrodes, whatever device you're going to be using for recording electrical signals from the brain or signals from the brain. We need to develop devices that we can put into the brain that are reliable and last for long periods of time,
某种最初的移动意图。所以当你第一次打算做一个动作时，该区域似乎比运动皮层更早亮起，而运动皮层随后在你实际执行动作时亮起。所以人们正在研究该区域的设备。目前还不清楚哪个区域更好，但两个区域都有效。目前该领域在开发可广泛提供给患者的神经假体方面面临的最大挑战是什么？在我看来有两个挑战。第一个是工程挑战，即开发电极，无论你打算使用什么设备来记录大脑的电信号或信号。我们需要开发可以放入大脑的设备，这些设备必须可靠且能持续很长时间，
meaning, you know, ideal if you want something to help a person, you want this to last at least a decade without having to go back in and replacing it. So there are challenges with that because the brain as a biological organ sees this device as a foreign body and tries to react to it and creates immune responses and tries to impede. the signals that we can record from. So over time, very often, our signals get weaker and weaker. What can you do to turn off that mechanism in the body? Do you use like anti-rejection drugs? No, no, no. What we try to do, what researchers are trying to do is develop materials that result in less reaction, immune reaction. materials that are, for example, softer, you know, instead of rigid electrodes, they try to build materials that are made of softer substances that are almost match the softness of the brain. And that results in perhaps less foreign body reaction.
意思是，如果你想用某种东西帮助一个人，你希望它至少能持续十年，而不需要回去更换它。这存在挑战，因为大脑作为一个生物器官，将这种设备视为异物，并试图对其做出反应，产生免疫反应并试图阻碍我们记录的信号。所以随着时间的推移，我们的信号往往会越来越弱。你能做些什么来关闭身体中的那种机制吗？你们使用抗排斥药物吗？不，不，不。我们试图做的是，研究人员正在尝试开发导致较少反应、免疫反应的材料。例如，更柔软的材料，你知道，而不是刚性电极，他们试图制造由更柔软物质制成的材料，这些物质几乎与大脑的柔软度相匹配。这可能会导致较少的异物反应。
So people are trying to do that right now. But no one has, to my knowledge, has tried to do, try to eliminate that foreign body reaction or that immune response. And if you have something like this implanted in your brain, what does this do say if at some point you need to have an MRI? Does it have to be removed? Like I was reading people with cochlear implants can't have MRIs as long as they have the implant. With the implant that we're using, it's not a good idea. have an MRI. We do MRIs before we implant to localize where we're going to put these electrodes, but we don't do it afterwards. So, no, it's not a good idea. So I was just wondering about
所以人们现在正在尝试这样做。但据我所知，没有人尝试过消除那种异物反应或免疫反应。如果你在大脑中植入了这样的东西，如果有一天你需要做核磁共振成像，这会怎么样？它必须被移除吗？我读到过植入人工耳蜗的人只要有植入物就不能做核磁共振成像。对于我们使用的植入物，做核磁共振成像不是一个好主意。我们在植入前会做核磁共振成像来定位我们要放置这些电极的位置，但之后我们不会做。所以，不，这不是一个好主意。所以我只是在想
the phantom limb sensations that some people experience after they've lost an arm or a leg. Does that phenomenon interfere with using a prosthesis? We haven't really experienced that issue. What we do notice is over time, subjects report to us that whatever device they're controlling, they seem to embody it. It almost feels like a part of their body. And they use words to describe that. For example, in the early days, this is not going back 15, 20 years ago, when they were controlling a cursor on a computer screen. initially they said, well, you know, I'm thinking about moving a mouse with my hand, which then moves the cursor to a certain location.
有些人失去手臂或腿后经历的幻肢感。这种现象会干扰使用假肢吗？我们并没有真正遇到过这个问题。我们确实注意到，随着时间的推移，受试者向我们报告说，无论他们控制什么设备，他们似乎都将其具体化了。它几乎感觉像是他们身体的一部分。他们用词来描述这一点。例如，在早期，这不是回到15、20年前，当他们控制电脑屏幕上的光标时。最初他们说，嗯，你知道，我在想用手移动鼠标，然后将光标移动到某个位置。
Over time, they say, well, I'm not thinking about the mouse. I'm not thinking about my hand. I'm just looking at this cursor. I am controlling the cursor directly. I'm not thinking about any intermediate translation from hand, you know, thoughts of my hand, thoughts of the mouse, and then ultimately the cursor. So it's almost like when you learn a foreign language, you know, early on, you translate into your native language.
随着时间的推移，他们说，嗯，我没有在想鼠标。我没有在想我的手。我只是看着这个光标。我正在直接控制光标。我没有在想任何从手，你知道，对手的思考，对鼠标的思考，最终到光标的中间转换。所以这几乎就像当你学习一门外语时，你知道，早期，你翻译成你的母语。
And then over time, you just speak it and understand it without that internal translation. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199 and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. Hey, I read about some recent research you've done that looked at mapping the movements of the
然后随着时间的推移，你只是说它并理解它，而没有那种内部翻译。你的夏天从家得宝的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用Next Grill四头燃气烤架开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需199美元，并用Hampton Bay West Grove七件套户外餐桌椅套装招待整个季节，仅需499美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为5月14日至5月27日，仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请参阅HomeDepot.com/pricematch。嘿，我读到了一些你最近做的研究，研究了舌头的运动映射。
tongue. Why was that something that you were interested in studying and what are the potential applications. Well, we were interested in the tongue because it's a soft body. It doesn't have joints. And so it's almost like infant, it has infinite degrees of freedom. It's just this floppy thing. And yet we're able to, well, first of all, when we speak, we can control it with exquisite control. we were looking at feeding and also when you feed and when you eat things your tongue is moving in various ways and I
为什么你对研究这个感兴趣，以及潜在的应用是什么？嗯，我们对舌头感兴趣，因为它是一个软体。它没有关节。所以它几乎像婴儿一样，它有无限的自由度。它只是这个软绵绵的东西。然而我们能够，首先，当我们说话时，我们可以极其精确地控制它。我们正在观察进食，当你进食和吃东西时，你的舌头在以各种方式移动，我
we were interested to what degree that information about the tongue shape and tongue movement was that information was encoded in the cortex because I always thought it was feeding was something that was done in the brain stem or in lower levels of the brain that we weren't really conscious of, and it was very kind of basic circuitry that
我们对舌头形状和舌头运动的信息在皮层中编码的程度感兴趣，因为我一直认为进食是脑干或大脑较低水平中完成的事情，我们并没有真正意识到，而且它是一种非常基础的电路，
had evolved over, you know, many, many, many thousands of millions of years. And the cortex didn't really care about that, because the cortex is usually thought about sort of as the kind of higher area of thought. And so I didn't think we'd get any information. And it turned out we had lots and lots of information about the tongue shape and movement. And it was remarkable. And we could decode the tongue shape with very good precision with recordings in the cortex. And the application for this, although we're not exploring this at this moment, is for people with difficulties with feeding and swallowing. Dysphagia is a serious problem, especially in the elderly. and so if we could develop a prosthetic that could help,
经过，你知道，成千上万百万年的进化。而皮层并不真正关心这一点，因为皮层通常被认为是某种更高层次的思维区域。所以我没想到我们会得到任何信息。结果发现我们有大量关于舌头形状和运动的信息。这太了不起了。我们可以通过皮层记录以非常好的精度解码舌头形状。虽然我们目前没有探索这一点，但它的应用是针对有进食和吞咽困难的人。吞咽困难是一个严重的问题，尤其是在老年人中。所以如果我们能开发出一种假体来帮助，
particularly with swallowing and feeding properly, that would be a great thing, I think. And when you say prosthetic in this case, I mean, the tongue is still there, so you're not replacing the tongue. What is the prosthetic device? So the prosthetic device would be, for example, you, when the patient wants to think about swallowing,
特别是正确地吞咽和进食，我认为那将是一件伟大的事情。当你在这个案例中说假体时，我的意思是，舌头还在那里，所以你不是在替换舌头。假体设备是什么？所以假体设备将是，例如，你，当患者想要考虑吞咽时，
because swallowing can be done either voluntarily or automatic. But let's say you want to voluntarily swallow. We pick up a signal from the cortex that says, okay, the person who wants to swallow, that's our trigger. And then we send that trigger to a set of electrodes that we implant in the muscles of the tongue and the hyoid, which is a structure below the tongue that helps and assists in swallowing. And we stimulate the muscles electrically to create the proper swallowing behavior.
因为吞咽既可以自愿完成，也可以自动完成。但假设你想自愿吞咽。我们从皮层获取一个信号，说，好的，想要吞咽的人，那是我们的触发器。然后我们将该触发器发送到我们植入舌头肌肉和舌骨的一组电极，舌骨是舌头下方有助于和辅助吞咽的结构。我们通过电刺激肌肉来产生适当的吞咽行为。
So that's the way the prosthetic would work, going from the brain to a set of electrodes that stimulate. And this is theoretical at this point? Is that what I'm hearing you say? This is theoretical. Yes. As we're talking, I mean, it's clear that this work has important applications. It's also very interesting at a basic science level. What are you learning about how the brain works from this research? What are you learning that we didn't know?
所以这就是假体的工作方式，从大脑到一组刺激电极。目前这还是理论上的吗？我听到的是这样吗？这是理论上的。是的。在我们交谈时，我的意思是，很明显这项工作有重要的应用。它在基础科学层面也非常有趣。你从这项研究中学到了关于大脑如何工作的东西吗？你学到了什么我们以前不知道的东西？
One thing we've learned is how flexible or plastic the brain is, because especially when we're trying to, we're using these non-biomimetic decoders. Remember, if I talked about that, that is you take signals from the brain, send them through an arbitrary decoder that it's not something that's natural for the subject. The subject has to learn how to activate the right pattern of activity of cells in order to move the device the right way. And what's remarkable is that both animals and humans can do that. And it doesn't take that much time. But, I mean, it takes some time, but it's like learning a motor skill, like learning how to ride your bike or play a musical instrument.
我们学到的一件事是大脑有多灵活或可塑，因为特别是当我们尝试时，我们正在使用这些非仿生解码器。记得我谈到过那个吗？那就是你从大脑获取信号，通过一个任意解码器发送它们，这不是受试者自然的东西。受试者必须学习如何激活正确的细胞活动模式，以便以正确的方式移动设备。令人惊奇的是，动物和人类都能做到这一点。而且不需要太多时间。但是，我的意思是，它需要一些时间，但这就像学习运动技能，比如学习如何骑自行车或演奏乐器。
It does take time, but you can learn how to do this. So you're taking now a part of the brain that had never been exposed to controlling this device in a completely arbitrary way. And it figures out how to do it. I think that that plasticity, that flexibility is remarkable. And by the way, another thing that other people are looking at as well is, I mean, you can, you don't have to focus just on the motor areas of the brain. You can look at other parts of the brain, and people have shown that even in other parts of the brain that you normally wouldn't think are associated with moving, you can use those, again,
确实需要时间，但你可以学会如何做到这一点。所以你现在正在利用大脑中从未接触过以完全任意方式控制该设备的部分。它弄清楚了如何做到这一点。我认为那种可塑性，那种灵活性是了不起的。顺便说一句，其他人也在研究的另一件事是，我的意思是，你可以，你不必只关注大脑的运动区域。你可以观察大脑的其他部分，人们已经证明，即使在大脑的其他部分，你通常不会认为与移动相关，你也可以使用它们，再次，
with this sort of non-biomatic approach where the subject or the animal has to learn and the animal learns and figures out how to do it. And so it just, it shows you the flexibility of the brain, which is remarkable. There are people out there, probably most famously Elon Musk, who are talking about a future where brain machine interfaces are used for augmenting people's abilities, not just for helping people who have disabilities. Do you see that happening? I mean, will we all someday be able to access the Internet directly with our brains? And is that something that you think we'll want to do? I'm not sure we want to do that, but it will probably happen if we solve a problem that still faces us in the field, which is a way to non-invasively implant or
用这种非仿生方法，受试者或动物必须学习，动物学习并弄清楚如何做到这一点。所以它只是，它向你展示了大脑的灵活性，这是了不起的。外面有人，可能最著名的是埃隆·马斯克，他们正在谈论一个脑机接口用于增强人们能力的未来，而不仅仅是帮助残疾人。你看到这种情况发生了吗？我的意思是，我们所有人终有一天都能用大脑直接访问互联网吗？这是你认为我们会想做的事情吗？我不确定我们是否想那样做，但如果我们解决了该领域仍然面临的问题，即一种非侵入性植入或
record signals from the brain. At the resolution, we need that. We need to. So I mean, right now you can use EEG electrodes that are sitting on the scalp and created a brain computer interface. They work not very well. So if you really want an effective brain computer interface, you need to access signals at the level of single neurons or small groups of neurons. And there isn't really a device out there that's non-invasive at the present moment. And so if it's not invasive, you know, how many people are really going to volunteer to have brain surgery, open up their skull? I mean, now there are technologies out there that are being, there are several companies out there right now, as we speak, that are trying to create minimally invasive technologies. So one approach, for example, is you only have to create a small little cut in the skull, very, very small, and slip in a set of electrodes.
记录大脑信号的方法，它可能会发生。在我们需要的分辨率下。我们需要。所以我的意思是，现在你可以使用坐在头皮上的脑电图电极并创建一个脑机接口。它们工作得不是很好。所以如果你真的想要一个有效的脑机接口，你需要获取单个神经元或一小群神经元水平的信号。目前还没有真正非侵入性的设备。所以如果它不是侵入性的，你知道，有多少人真的会自愿进行脑部手术，打开他们的头骨？我的意思是，现在有技术正在被，现在有几家公司，就在我们说话的时候，正在尝试创造微创技术。所以一种方法，例如，你只需要在头骨上做一个小切口，非常非常小，然后滑入一组电极。
And these electrodes are sitting on the brain, not in the brain. Very high density electrodes. It's minimal, but it's still surgery. Another approach is by a company called Synchron out of Australia. They're trying to implant electrodes through the. blood vessels, which they then feed up. So they stick that up. I'm not sure exactly where. And somewhere in the body, they stick the electrodes inside the blood vessels, and they feed it up to the brain and then record signals from the brain through the blood vessels, through the
这些电极坐在大脑上，而不是在大脑里。高密度电极。它是微创的，但仍然是手术。另一种方法是由澳大利亚的一家名为Synchron的公司提出的。他们正试图通过血管植入电极，然后他们将其送入。所以他们把它插进去。我不确定具体在哪里。在身体的某个地方，他们把电极插进血管里，然后把它送到大脑，然后通过血管，通过血管壁记录大脑的信号。
walls of the blood vessels. I'm not sure if that's actually going to work because you still have, you're not getting really, really close to the neurons. But those. are two approaches that are minimally invasive, that might result in larger adoption of this technology, but I don't know. We don't have the technology. It just doesn't exist to actually non-invasively record from the brain at the resolution we need. What are you working on now? And what are your biggest research priorities? Our research priorities right now is to augment these brain machine interfaces with sensory feedback. So with movement, and this is something I ignored for years, but it's very important. So when we normally move, we rely besides vision, which is important,
我不确定这是否真的有效，因为你仍然有，你并没有真正非常接近神经元。但那些是两种微创方法，可能会导致这种技术的更大采用，但我不知道。我们没有这项技术。它根本不存在，无法以我们需要的分辨率非侵入性地记录大脑。你现在在做什么？你最大的研究重点是什么？我们现在的研究重点是利用感觉反馈来增强这些脑机接口。所以对于运动，这是我多年来忽略的事情，但它非常重要。所以当我们正常移动时，除了视觉（这很重要）之外，我们依赖，
we have to be able to see what we're doing. But we can do a lot of things without vision. And what's really important is touch, especially when you're interacting with objects. You want to touch an object like a cup. You want to make sure you grab it with enough force so it doesn't slip, but not too much that you break it. So the touch is important. And another sense called proprioception or kinesthesia, the sense of feeling your limbs in space and how they're moving and where they are in space. Those two senses are really important for normal movement. And I know, we know this from patients that lack that sense, those two senses. If you go on YouTube, you can see videos, and they're severely motor disabled. Even though their motor system is completely intact,
我们必须能够看到我们在做什么。但我们可以在没有视觉的情况下做很多事情。真正重要的是触觉，尤其是在你与物体交互时。你想触摸一个像杯子一样的物体。你想确保你用足够的力抓住它，这样它就不会滑落，但不要太用力以至于弄碎它。所以触觉很重要。另一种感觉称为本体感觉或动觉，即在空间中感受你的肢体以及它们如何移动以及它们在空间中的位置的感觉。这两种感觉对于正常运动非常重要。我知道，我们从缺乏那种感觉的患者那里知道这一点，那两种感觉。如果你去YouTube，你可以看到视频，他们严重运动残疾。即使他们的运动系统完全完好，
they look like they've had a motor injury, but they don't have those senses. So that's what we're trying to do right now. And currently, we're augmenting these systems with a sense of touch. So what we do is we have now two human subjects at the University of Chicago, and there are others as well at the University of Pittsburgh with whom we work. And these subjects have electrodes both in the motor areas, motor cortex, for control, but electrodes also in the somatosensory cortex, which is right next to the motor cortex. and we stimulate electrically. Instead of record, we send signals into the electrodes, electrical signals, to stimulate those areas near the electrodes. And these subjects report feeling tactile touch sensations on the fingertips.
他们看起来像受过运动损伤，但他们没有那些感觉。所以这就是我们现在正在尝试做的事情。目前，我们正在用触觉增强这些系统。所以我们现在在芝加哥大学有两名人类受试者，在匹兹堡大学也有其他人与我们合作。这些受试者在运动区域（运动皮层）都有电极用于控制，但在体感皮层（就在运动皮层旁边）也有电极。我们进行电刺激。我们不是记录，我们发送信号到电极，电信号，来刺激电极附近的那些区域。这些受试者报告说在指尖上有触觉感。
So now we now have what's called a bidirectional brain computer interface. We're going both out of the brain and into the brain in both directions. And so with that, you can now imagine a scenario where a subject is controlling a robotic hand. They can reach out, grab an object like a cup. They then feel a cup and manipulate it in a way that they don't do damage and they don't break the cup. And they feel it. They actually feel what it feels like on their fingertips. So that's what we're developing now.
所以我们现在有了所谓的双向脑机接口。我们正在双向进出大脑。因此，你可以想象一个场景，受试者正在控制一只机械手。他们可以伸出手，抓住一个像杯子一样的物体。然后他们感觉到杯子并以一种不会造成损坏且不会弄碎杯子的方式操纵它。他们感觉到了它。他们实际上感觉到了指尖上的感觉。所以这就是我们现在正在开发的。
So we've mentioned the sense of touch. We've talked about a little bit, the hearing because cochlear implants have been around for a while now. You talked about swallowing, but there are several other senses. I'm just wondering, is anybody looking into prosthetic eyes? Will we ever be able to give people back vision? Yes. So there are several groups looking at artificial vision. And, yeah, that's, it's not, it hasn't resulted in a commercial product as far as I know.
所以我们提到了触觉。我们谈到了一点，听觉，因为人工耳蜗已经存在一段时间了。你谈到了吞咽，但还有其他几种感觉。我只是在想，有没有人在研究假眼？我们将来能让人恢复视力吗？是的。所以有几个小组在研究人工视觉。而且，是的，据我所知，它还没有产生商业产品。
Although it's close. But there's, so yeah, there are many groups looking at that. They're either, they're different approaches to that, either stimulating the retina in the eye or stimulating the cortex, the visual cortex, or something that my colleague, my good friend, a long-term friend at Mass General, is developing a stimulator that stimulates in between the cortex. and the retina called the thalamus, in the visual thalamus. And that may have certain advantages. So yes, there's a lot going on there.
虽然很接近了。但是有，所以是的，有很多小组在研究它。他们要么，有不同的方法，要么刺激眼睛里的视网膜，要么刺激皮层，视觉皮层，或者我的同事，我的好朋友，在麻省总医院的长期朋友正在开发一种刺激器，刺激皮层和视网膜之间，称为丘脑，在视觉丘脑中。这可能有一些优势。所以是的，那里发生了很多事情。
But it hasn't progressed as well as or as fast as like the cochlear implant, for example. But they're working on it. Well, this is all amazing work. It sounds like magic. And I want to thank you for your efforts. And also thank you for talking with me today. Thank you for having me. I really appreciate it.
但它没有像人工耳蜗那样进展得那么好或那么快。但他们正在研究它。嗯，这都是了不起的工作。听起来像魔法。我想感谢你的努力。也感谢你今天与我交谈。谢谢你邀请我。我真的很感激。
It was really fun. If you'd like to read more about Dr. Hatsopoulosys and other researchers work on neuroprosthetics, go to the July issue of APA's magazine, Monitor on Psychology, at www.apa.org, backslash, monitor. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman.
这真的很有趣。如果你想阅读更多关于哈佐普洛斯博士和其他研究人员在神经假体方面的工作，请访问美国心理学会杂志《心理学监测》七月刊，网址为www.apa.org/monitor。你可以在我们的网站www.speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Spotify、YouTube或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你听到的内容，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件给我们speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·威纳曼制作。
Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon. at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply.
感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。在Ralph's享受更多省钱方式，比如每个过道的低价。当你下载Ralph's应用程序时，你可以每周通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多。此外，你可以赚取燃油积分，在加油站每加仑最多可节省1美元。在Ralph's，你每次购物都可以享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。所以每天都能轻松省大钱，享受优惠和奖励。Ralph's SoCal，服务超过150年。储蓄可能因州而异。适用燃油限制。
See site for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
详情请参阅网站。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。